un gran pantano con edificaciones en el
medio así se percibe una parte de la
Ciudad de Lima Capital de Perú tras el
paso del ciclón yaku el fenómeno
meteorológico que golpeó al norte del
país de manera sorpresiva causando daños
en la infraestructura Vial y a los
servicios básicos la verdad que no yo
estaba recién estoy como cinco años pero
nunca había pasado es la primera vez que
casi nos vemos sorprendido estamos in
comunicados y más aún las vistas de Los
laureles están reventadas y no puede
subir el carro de cisterna para que nos
pueda facilitar con el líquido elemental
que es el agua los ciudadanos se han
unido para trabajar en pro de la
limpieza y recuperar lo posible en sus
hogares las autoridades han declarado el
estado de emergencia para atender la
situación de acuerdo al escenario más
crítico que ha hecho el senami que el
entre ayer y el día de hoy 14 para 15
iba a suceder lo que sucedió esperemos
que las próximas horas se pronuncie el
senami y diga Cuál va a ser los
escenarios críticos de acuerdo con
medios locales el daño en las
principales vías de la zona norte del
país podría generar pérdidas millonarias
para la economía de esta zona de Perú
especialmente en Los pequeños negocios
que están al borde de la quiebra
[Música]